hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen and
today I am watching Brokeback Mountain
this was a film that in my small town
growing up was only kind of whispered
about I know it was a mainstream film
but it was not something that was in my
household it was not something that we
were going out as a family to see very
like oh my gosh so taboo so I definitely
didn't see this in 2005 and I have heard
it's beautiful I've heard it's very sad
it's kind of long so I hope it's not
like all sad I'll be fine I'm not gonna
cry it's gonna be fine sweet great no
tears for me let's do it
[Music]
totally fine okay so in what's
definitely sad honestly there wasn't as
much conflict as I thought there was
going to be I thought initially there
was gonna be a lot more people opposing
than the gay there was obviously
conflicts that they couldn't be together
but not in the way that I thought there
was going to be I also really wish they
could have cast men who identified as
gay but that being said I think that the
actors were phenomenal they were all
really really good the performances were
very strong and it was touching week it
was so touching you guys new hot take
Brokeback Mountain is touching Jake
Gyllenhaal is kind of this I would say
like kind of metro like a little
feminine for a leading character type of
actor Heath Ledger is amazing just
always just was so good and this film
was so subtle he was so subtle in
everything that he did and his character
it called for that it was just so good
and and complex and oh it was so good it
just I think they were perfectly cast I
think that their wives were perfectly
cast I know a lot of people don't love
Anne Hathaway but I just be enjoying it
that's the way I I'm very much
identified with her like excitedness all
the time
and that's why people don't like her and
so I also identify with that I thought
she was really gonna miss Michelle
Williams though broke my heart and this
she was so soft and beautiful and kind
and loving and perfect for the role of
Heath Ledger's wife it's kind of it is
it there is a story but it's kind of
like a non-story like it's just a lot of
back and forth between them living with
their families and then seeing each
other and being with each other on the
mountain things happen in between that
of course but it's just a lot of like
showing this
dreadful story of how they can't live
together but I feel like they can't live
together specifically Heath Ledger's
character and then them trying to make
it work I wrote first half hours showing
them protecting and tending to cattle on
Brokeback Mountain and then oh damn they
have sex I love this first sex scene
that they have because Jake Gyllenhaal's
character really makes it happen cuz I
don't think Heath Ledger's character
would have ever made the first move on
that and and he's angry about it and
he's got such anger and almost like hate
in this sex scene because he is a tough
cowboy in the 60s living in Wyoming and
that's just not okay I mean it was okay
it is okay yes but in that time period
and in those circumstances a lot of
people do not agree I wrote I'm just
gonna say it right now Jake Gyllenhaal
he's got great lips
they both acknowledge that they're not
queer and then they have a super-sweet
makeout session so the logistics out of
the way hit them they're like all right
back to business then they part ways
after the summer is over
and there's this beautiful moment where
he breaks down into this corner as Jake
Gyllenhaal is driving away and he starts
crying and it's just oh my god it's so
good
so Heath Ledger's character Ennis and
his wife Alma have two kids they're
having a lot of sex meanwhile Jake
Gyllenhaal's character Jack Jack twist
with a name he is just sad and really
bad at doing rodeo which same that's a
big mood sad and terrible at Rohingya
and hathaway cousins and she's gonna
fill the hole that Heath filled no I
wrote oh shit Jake Gyllenhaal and a half
we have a kid oh shit Jake since Keith
the postcard oh shit he visit teeth for
years go by they see each other again
and oh my god it's like the steamy
scene ever Jake pulls up Heath goes down
to get him and they just start kissing
and it's very I will say that they acted
their butts off in this film I think
it's really good
again would have been super cool if it
was cast you know by actual people but
great job they did such a good job all
my C's and that's really the decline of
their marriage you know I feel I
understand that I guess but it's just so
it's so heartbreaking to watch because
she's such a sweet character
it's a terrible awful situation but like
I just wish they could have confronted
and made right of course they don't
I wrote oh shit is that Ellen Page no
it's Linda Cardellini from freaks and
geeks scooby-doo they look very similar
then I wrote what is that Anna Faris oh
my god is that David Harbor from
stranger things Wow huh is that the girl
from house of cards look at a lot of
people in bit then I mean back and forth
all these like they're just going back
and forth from being together not being
together but then he gets word through a
shitty postcard that Jack has died you
find out that he died from a tire
accident which was probably you know and
homophobic thing so Heath Ledger goes up
to to Jake's bedroom and sees that he
kept his old shirt that had a bunch of
blood on it for one of their fights and
it was just so sweet it shows that Heath
is living in this trailer and he's
saying that it's okay for his daughter
to get married all this stuff just
really mundane things like he's just
living his sad existence of a life
without his partner that he loves and
and the end shot is just him looking at
the shirt and his sad trailer was like
no furniture
and it sucks there were definitely some
problems with it but overall it was
really good though I don't know that I
ever need to watch it again we've come
so far as like a society with
gbt things and content and I think
there's some other really good options
that aren't nearly as sad though I do I
do enjoy indulging and sad things every
once in a while so we'll see who else
just loves to cry a filter because I do
Brokeback Mountain predictions Doug
recommended this one for TNS happy game
or sad gay you tell me Cody Cody said I
also haven't seen it but from what I
know we don't really get happy gay
mainstream movies unless Nathan Lane is
in them - true - sure wheezy waiter says
sad definitely sad you'll cry and
realize its importance but one happy
queer boobies yes a lot of people
thought that I was gonna cry at this and
I didn't I didn't cry he'll be annoyed
that I wish I knew how to quit you is a
meme when it's actually a pretty
heartbreaking moment / line there are a
lot of things in this movie that I feel
that way I have always known that this
was a heavy sad important film but also
I think a lot of people deal with that
uncomfortableness and turn it into a
joke so there's not like a lotta means
of this film that seeing it in its
actual context it's like that's deep
that is some heavy shit and eight that
shouldn't be a joke but it is of course
cuz you know the Internet should have
won best picture instead of awful crash
I've not seen crash either but yeah
totally absolutely was crash good
and the Oscar for Best Picture goes to
Brokeback Mountain
[Music]
you'll be weirded out by the painful and
kind of inaccurate sex scenes I like the
pain that was portrayed in them was that
was like really good because especially
with Keith's character I feel like he
was so scared of who he was and I feel
like that really came through in this
sexy I don't know I kind of feel like I
dug that because it felt real to me I
don't know is that an accurate I don't
know oh yeah this is a frustrating lease
add one you will be cheerful and
possibly angry at some point and want to
write fanfic to give them a happy ending
absolutely
this might be the first time that I feel
like I need to set this engine right
thank you so much for watching I'm not
really sure what I'm doing next week I
might go back to Simpsons with my little
brother but I've also got a couple
videos with Doug in the works for
Tamra's never seen some things that he
hasn't seen either so one of those will
be in the works for next week thank you
again for checking it out I'll see you
all soon
[Music]
[Applause]
you